voila in view humble of olive alien  veteran cast vicariously as both victim  and villain by the vicissitudes of fate  this visage new mere veneer of vanity is  a vestige of the Vox Populi now vacant  vanished  however this valorous visitation of a  bygone vexation stands vivified and has  vowed to vanquish these venal and  virulent vermin bang guarding vice and  vouchsafing the violently vicious and  voracious violation of policy only the  only verdict is vengeance a vendetta  elders a votive not in vain for the  value and veracity of such shall one day  vindicate the vigilant and virtuous  verily this vichyssoise of verbiage of  his most verbose so let me simply add  that it is my very good honor to meet  you and you may call me Lee  you